[Music]
life
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value giv values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we get no value to ha run homie look
what I become I'm I'm the
one okay so podcast episode number 321
many of you have been waiting for this
uh this is a special one I was with the
governor yesterday he came and uh spend
a few few minutes with the family the
kids my son was like I met the governor
it was great we were at the you know
Miami Dolphins game they even won uh but
I know I hear this is your first uh live
podcast for an hour that you're going to
so it's an honor to have you here we're
truly honored by this and appreciate
your setting up shop in Florida and and
doing all you're doing down here yes I
told you earlier we're going to make
Fort Lauderdale the the Hollywood of the
Burbank of East Coast but it's going to
take us a minute anyways let's get right
into it we got only one hour together so
first things first for me uh when I
watch you very closely I told you this
yesterday and I'm going to say it on
camera as well so it's very aligned with
exactly the message I give to my son
when Dylan came and he shook hands with
you I said Dylan do you know who this
man is I said this man is the governor
he's the reason why we moved to the
great state of Florida so you're the
reason why we came here and when we were
in Texas we had our insurance company we
build it we moved it from LA uh to
Addison Texas we had it there we grew it
to 45 50,000 agents we sold it a year
and a half ago 2 and a half years ago I
said babe we got to move to a state
we're looking at everywhere here we're
looking at Greenwich we're looking at
New York we're looking at Newport Beach
we're looking at stain in Dallas we're
looking at Nashville we're looking at
Tampa and then finally we made a
decision to come out here for a couple
different reasons so you know I think
sometimes when if we go back uh three
years ago you got a lot of hate people
were criticizing your left and right and
and I want to first start off by listing
all your Victory is what you've done I
think the world needs to know this and I
think this needs to be on a greatest
hits constantly over and over again for
people to know what you did and how hard
it was for you to do what you did so one
I'm a guy that lived in California I saw
what uh Disneyland against Disney World
when everybody was like well let's see
what's going to happen this the best
case study of California against Florida
and then one day Bob Iger comes in and
says I'm out October of 2020 he left in
Nome camp and the next day they
announced they're letting go of 28,000
employees but you kept it open so Disney
World excels the small businesses around
are doing good but California is getting
destroyed okay uh everybody would say
you shut down you shut down Florida you
shut down Florida April 1st you
announced the 2020 it was like three or
four weeks we were here and then free it
was a decision that a lot of people made
man during that month we had people
flocking to Florida even then we had
golf courses going we had Recreation
protected churches all those things so
you know we basically did a loose of the
federal guidelines but I was being
criticized from the other side saying
that this was uh that I wasn't doing
enough on that regard and then obviously
we reversed course Very quickly and then
led the country for the few years and by
the way to to some of the Republicans
that criticize you to say he shut it
down it that wasn't a shutdown that was
a test to see how things were reacting
to see what it was going to be like and
then you went back to business as usual
based on what you saw UFC 261 first uh
full capacity event that took place uh
April 24th 2021 in Jacksonville
uh then you have LeBron I don't know if
he's ever seen well but the that we
actually did the first live sporting
event Co came everyone freaked out all
the sports League shut down right Dana
White was trying to find a deserted
island so I called him I said Dana just
do it in Florida and he's like he's like
all right he's like where can I do it I
was like wherever you want and and he
wanted to make sure that the local mayor
would also be supportive cuz he's like I
know I like look I'll overrule him he's
like no I want to I want to make sure
everyone wants us there so the Jackson
mayor was a republican wanted him to do
so I think it was the first week of May
2020 when people well you know governor
of California saying don't even leave
your house we did a UFC now we didn't
have the the the stadium filled but to
do that was important because people
were acting like we couldn't live life
yes Des so you had that and then so
because we stood stood stood uh stood up
for that Dana's like I'm always going to
come back to Jacksonville so he's come
back to Jacksonville every year now and
and by the way not only that the the UFC
that did in Miami was a record-breaking
at the gate even bigger than New York
Dana said in an interview the post fight
you know he said this was uh felt like
what La was 10 years ago even more than
that LeBron James won a championship
because of you these guys were the BLM
guys but they ran the playoffs here
which was full of cont controversy and
contradictions there NBA bubble that's
right but I can go on and on and on and
talk about how parents feel comfortable
here you know what you've done with uh
uh the uh you know limiting the gender
affirming care the E verify Von wasteful
spending I know the insurance crisis I
made a video about it today how they're
trying to kind of give you a hard time
because you stand up to Black Rock and
ESG and then cbdc which was one of the
biggest ones that you guys rarely talk
about I'd love for you to talk more
about that crypto communities now become
crypto capital in the world is Miami
it's here it's what you guys have done
and then I talked about that before but
I want to get into an issue right now
that we're dealing with I lived in Iran
10 years okay and whatever we turn on
right now we're seeing Israel
Palestine couple months ago was Ukraine
Russia now it's is Palestine everyone's
talking about it it's a issue that's uh
uh very disturbing when when we saw the
video of people coming down and then
what they did at that Rave the party and
then you're seeing the videos the
kidnapp and all that stuff taking place
and then the numbers came out today
8,500 on the Palestinian side on what
Israel has done you got 1500 on the
Israeli side it's a very complicated
situation here because on one end you're
seeing how many billionaires are pulling
money out of giving money to Harvard I
mean that's where you went to Yale
that's also where you went into and Penn
and all these different universities
what are you guys do how come you're not
supporting this you're supporting
Palestine you're quiet about it and then
on one end I'm sitting there asking a
question saying how did Netanyahu not
know if you got the best secret
intelligence in the world mad how did
you not know this was going to take
place and the other question becomes how
Egypt why are you not taking you know
refugees to come to your country what do
you know about your neighbor that the
rest of us don't know these are two
questions that we can both entertain but
this the question I had for
you I feel the Democrats have owned the
black vote
for decades that they feel like no
matter what they do they are always
going to get the black vote that's kind
of how they treat them so a lot of
blacks are not happy about it but guess
what every year 84 to 88% vote Democrat
I get a feeling that
Netanyahu or Israel this is a question a
lot of people are thinking about
including myself sees the Americans as
the same way America's got our back we
can do whatever we want to do and
they're gonna always have our back
matter of fact even in a
private conversation that he was having
in 2001 I want to play this clip he's
having a conversation with a couple
people this has been reported on by wapo
in 2010 Al jazir I want to say in 2001
and all over the place if you don't mind
paying attention to this video and then
I'll ask the question here's Netanyahu
privately having a conversation in 01 go
ahead go ahead Rob and play
[Music]
it
foree
[Music]
AB 80% Americans support us it's absurd
you know we can kind of get what we want
out of them so this is my concern I'm
America first I live here my kids live
here my kids are in Florida because I
feel the safest here I don't mind my
allies having good relationships with me
I'm okay with my allies I have a problem
with my allies using me as a card to
Abus that get out of jail card and then
eventually this thing can turn around
and lead into World War III because
World War I 19 million people died 260
million people died if the third one
happens at that trajectory it's 200
million people do you think
Netanyahu is kind of using a get out of
jail card to do what he wants to do and
what he's been wanting to do with
Palestine all these years now look I I
don't think I mean I think you pointed
out how does they have the best security
in the world and yet this is a massive
attack on their civilian population so
my sense is in in Israel is that the
public is very disenchanted with the
government I think they view it as
having been a big problem that this
happened uh and so I think they're now
in a situation where they have to say
okay you know you have this group on the
in the Gaza Strip which by the way is
not occupied territory Israel pulled out
in 2006 they elected Hamas and I think
that's been a big mistake because most
of the capital goes into the terrorist
infrastructure but I think they're in a
situation where uh you can't live with
with that type of a threat right on your
border and so they have to deal with
that I don't think it's a question of
America get out of jail free I think
honestly they're going to do what
they're going to do we've been they
we've been a strong Ally of theirs and
vice versa over the years but we've
deployed troops all over the world we've
never deployed troops uh there they've
always fought uh with with their own
Army so I I think the the I don't think
it's a question of manipulating America
I think it's you you have the American
people by and large have affinity for
Israel uh part largely I think more from
in in our Christian Community than
anything just based on on the history of
the judeo-christian tradition and how
it's informed this country so I think it
is unique in terms of the the Affinity
that our country has for Israel because
of the of the Biblical history and
people's uh adherence to the
judeo-christian tradition yeah earlier
today he said you know this whole thing
about Ceasar I don't know if you saw
that or not where he's like look uh
we're not going to cease fire did
America cease fire with Pearl Harbor did
America cease fire with 911 dider Am SE
far we're not going to either ride which
by the way I understand his position my
concern isn't his position my concern is
this going so extreme where it backfires
you're seeing what happened at airports
yesterday in Russia I'm sure you saw
that clip it's all over the place what
do we do to prevent this from coming
back in our soil I'm a product of Iran I
lived in Iran 10 years and I remember
when Jimmy Carter was like well you know
human rights you know the Sha's got to
get rid of these three thou 3,000
political prisoners he did and then
Al-Qaeda and you know Osama Bin Laden
all this thing came out of it 10 20 30
years later we got a 911 here so are you
worried the position he's taken could
have some residual effects that come to
America I don't think it's because of
that I am worried about terrorism in
America largely because of what our own
government has done to let people in
illegally from all around the world
you've had people almost 8 million have
come in we know people have come in from
China Russia Middle East all these
places 140 people on the terror watch
list that our own government
acknowledges I mean so you figure
there's a lot more than that uh and if
you look at 911 part of the reason that
happened was a failure of the
immigration system too I mean those
people did not they weren't here on
valid visas or they had their visas
expired the hijackers so my fear is just
you have so many people that have
flooded in uh some of them are part of
the drug cartel some of them just want
to work some of them are criminal aliens
and then some of them I think would be
potential terrorists and I think there's
going to be a terrorist attack in this
country that we're going to be able to
trace back to the Border and so I look
at it and say okay you got to protect
your own people first and foremost
territorial Integrity of your country
must be enforced you can't just let the
inmates run the Asylum and I think what
we're seeing in some of these places in
Europe um in some of these areas is they
had immigration policies that were
bringing people in that didn't want to
assimilate you know my view is is like
you have nobody has a right to come to
America uh of course illegally but even
legally it's a privilege to be able to
do that the things the two things that
has to be is you got to believe in this
country's ideals and you want to you got
to want to assimilate I don't think it's
helpful to bring in massive numbers of
people that are going to try to bring
foreign cultures in and that's I think
what's happened there's no go zones in
France and in uh and in Britain and some
of these places that's not a recipe for
Success so I think Europe's going to
have a very difficult time with these
tensions bubbling up I think we have the
ability to still be smart about what
we're doing here in the United States um
and avoid some of what what they've
walked themselves into I I just I just
hope and and pray that this thing
doesn't get ugly I know you got three
kids I got four we uh uh you know when
you think from your kids perspective
it's a little bit concerning when you're
seeing this is not calming down it's
getting worse and it's like at a bar
it's like what' you say what you say and
everybody's like did you see what he
said and it's just getting more and more
and more heated and we got to kind of
figure out bring it down so Republican
party let's transition to the next topic
there's a bit of a civil war going on at
Republican party there's three uh uh I
think factions right now the Republican
party one is the anti-establishment
faction okay you can put the Matt Gates
of the world and some of those guys in
there and the magga crowd and Trump and
those those guys in there you can put
the establishment crowd in there some of
the guys that are the establishment guys
that do well some would call you
anti-establishment at times some would
call you establishment you're like a
hybrid and then the third could be the
list Cheney the Lincoln project which
the old Lincoln project which they had
some momentum they don't have the legs
they do today but there's a little bit
of the Rhino Community for yourself when
you see see this speaker of the house
McCarthy Mike Johnson stuff that we've
not seen before
right you see this division taking place
do you see yourself as a unifier or do
you see yourself as a
revolutionary well I think I think in
some ways we're both I mean we would
come to Washington and upend the Order
of way that they've done business and I
don't think we've had a president do
that since Ronald Reagan when he came in
in 1980 um I think that uh we need
somebody that can come in across the
board on all these issues the bureau Ry
the border the economy and do this
Implement these changes and do it for an
8-year period I think that that's very
important but I also am somebody who in
my reelection as Florida Governor I got
97% of registered Republicans that was a
record I mean normally if you get 90%
that's considered very very good we've
got 97% you destroyed it it wasn't even
close well but the thing is is is we
were able to bring people together
because we had a strong vision and we
were delivering results for people so I
think what what they're missing in
Washington is so much of what the the
part's doing is theater um you know you
have guys out there that are that are
putting on a show and that's on all
sides I mean ultimately these Lincoln
project people it's all about clicks for
them and and money and all that stuff
and that and it's like okay that
ultimately is not what you're judged on
in terms of being a leader you're judged
on are you actually producing results
are you moving the electorate in a way
that is going to be better in Florida we
produce results but we also moved the
electorate we took an electorate that
was down the middle 50/50 and we turned
it into a 6040 Victory now we're
considered a strong a red state that was
not the case in fact you go back before
I got elected governor people were
saying this was going to go Blue that's
what people thought they thought and in
fact during coid you heard a lot of that
because they're oh my gosh Governor Des
sandis has schools open he's got all
this stuff open he so unpopular all this
stuff he's not going to be able to to
win rection their people were saying
that and they were acting like this was
an opportunity for Democrats turned out
it was the opposite so I think what you
need to kind of you need to unify the
Republicans and you need to win in
enough Independence if you can't do that
you're just not going to win and I'm the
only one that really has a track record
of doing that uh in Florida we want
independent voters by 18 percentage
points I mean that's really what you
need but we didn't do it by contorting
ourselves or trying to put our finger on
the Wind we did what we believed we told
people the truth we delivered results
and we were able to track people there
are people out there they don't need to
agree with you on everything but if they
see that you're telling them the truth
if they know you'll fight for them when
the chips are down they will support you
so we've got to do more of that I think
as the Republicans but look I I was I
was conservative against the Republican
establishment before Donald Trump ever
ran and I'm the same you know a lot of
those people um in DC you know they
don't they don't want me to be to be to
be the candidate they opposed me
everything we did in Florida they've
opposed they opposed us having the State
open they opposed us having schools open
they opposed us fighting uh the the vax
mandates and stopping those they opposed
us beating Disney in the parents rights
fight they've opposed us on getting
critical race Theory out of our schools
theyve opposed us on Banning Sanctuary C
they oppos me when we sent illegal
aliens to Martha's Vineyard so that
cabal of Republicans is basically a
surrender caucus they don't actually
ever win victories they're totally fine
being the junior Partners to the
Democrats in the entrenched DC ruling
class that is totally unacceptable and I
fought those guys the whole time I'm
really the only guy that has just beat
the left on issue after issue I mean
we've beat them across the board we've
thoroughly um uh pushed them out of of
of taking over institutions I mean for
example higher education I now have
tenur professors in Florida every five
years they have to go undergo review
they can be let go I put seven
conservatives on the trustee board at
new College they fired the president
they they got rid of Dei and now they
have a classical liberal arts college
like Hillsdale College and they're
bringing in new professors they're
they're cycling out some of the old
professors the media will say oh there's
a brain drain leaving new College in
this stuff and I'm thinking to myself
well wait a minute if a professor of
intersectional Marxism is leaving
Florida that is not a negative Florida
that's a good thing what we've done in
K12 schools to protect parents rights
and I think if you look at the larger
reason why the country's in Decline part
of I think a big part of it is the left
anytime there's any any vacuum they just
they get in so they're in education
bureaucracy now Corporate America with
things like ESG and the whole di agenda
so they corrupt these institutions and
then that ends up being weaponized
against regular Americans and so in
Florida we've beat them on the
institutional level and no other
Republican can say that they've done
that because I understand that you can
win a superficial policy fight and you
need to win those in the legisl or
whatnot but if the left controls every
institution in our society then
ultimately uh it's a losing proposition
so Florida I think the reason we're the
free state of Florida yes no income tax
yes coid Freedom all that important but
we have beat the left on the
institutional level listen the the one
of the things things that was the most
impressive with you is your dog fight
you fought it wasn't like you backed on
you're not afraid you got brass you're
willing to get up there and throw you
know with anybody and that was that's
actually very attractive cuz we need
that in America today especially as a
parent people that want to create jobs I
want low regulation you want that but I
want to go back to the question about
unifying and the Revolutionary so are
you is is the goal more for the party to
win policies to win or for your personal
Ambitions of you being a president which
one's more important the results 100%
I'm a vessel for those results uh you're
judged by the results you do um it's not
about holding the position it's about
what you do to make the country better
and to make make the people Freer fair
enough I want to play this clip for you
then I got a question for you this is a
campaign video that most people haven't
seen this is from five year five years
ago not this one go to the other one the
YouTube one right there I want to play
this clip and I got a question for you
at the end go for it everyone knows my
husband Rona santis is endorsed by
President Trump but he's also an amazing
dad Ron loves playing with the kids
build the wall he reads stories then Mr
Trump said you're fired I love that part
he's teaching Madison to talk make
America great again people say Ron's all
Trump but he is so much more big league
so good I just thought you should know
Rona santis for governor so what
happened what happened between the two
of you guys well nothing well first of
all that um you know just understand
like that's obviously a tongue and cheek
we were having fun with of course it's
actually funny video but here's the
thing about it uh when you're doing
these campaigns you want to get as much
free media as possible so I knew that
that would cause the corporate media to
light their hair on fire and they did
and so they just kept playing it for me
so we didn't even have to really pay for
the ad and everything and we're just
doing out and so part of it is then ad
gets out what do the average voters see
they say hey this is a guy with a this
beautiful wife young kids everything
like that and that that that kind of
helped us there but um you know I did
more for him in his 2020 reelection than
any other elected official I raised him
more money than any elected official I I
got people in Florida to support him
that were not happy with him because he
didn't fire fouchy he didn't do anything
to stop the BLM riots in the summer of
2020 which we didn't tolerate in Florida
but you had cities burning down all
across this country and there was
nothing done so there was a lot of
people that I got on his team and I
worked really hard and we you know
really delivered the victory because
they in October of 2020 I mean his
campaign was putting out stuff oh if he
loses Florida it's all because of the
governor okay well you know I I I
brought in more Republicans here so I
was happy Happ to do that but the
reality is is okay what about going
forward what's the vehicle to make the
country great again and we need somebody
who's going to be able to Galvanize
support and then attract the needed
Personnel to be able to to deal with the
administrative State and then you need
to actually be able to deliver results I
mean one of the things on there that
that it's talking about is is the wall
remember build the wall and have Mexico
pay for it what he now says on the
campaign Trail I mean honestly honks me
off because he says that if you believed
what he said then that you're somehow a
loser that's what he said the other day
and then before he says all these people
saying that I'm gonna that I'm going to
have Mexico pay there's no legal
mechanism in Mexico then you look at
what he said in 2016 he was saying he
was going to have Mexico pay but here's
the thing about execution there actually
is a way to have Mexico pay the way you
have Mexico pay is you impose fees on
remittances that people send back to
Mexico who work here Central America
anywhere in the world you you'd raise
billions of dollars and you would
actually be able to construct the wall
so um and you know look I'll tell you I
was
disappointed uh you know as he's leaving
office did he did he use that time to to
fire fouchy or to do any of that no he
actually gave fouchy an award a
presidential Commendation on January
19th 2021 and that that that that was
personal for me because fouchy
everything we did in Florida fouchy
attacked us on andrees can we lower
Governor's audio down like a notch it
just all of a sudden spiked please
continue call forward so fouchy he would
do interviews with local TV Affiliates
in Florida bashing us oh they're
Reckless they shouldn't do that he he
attacked us for because I forced the
schools to be open I mean I didn't
really have the the normal Authority I
was using emergency powers and
leveraging those with the funding to be
able to do and that save the bacon for a
lot of kids and it was like it was
obvious after a few months that this
fouchy was totally off his rocker but he
was doing real damage because anytime
he'd go to the podium his pronouncements
were treated like you know like the pope
speaking ex cathra to to Catholics and
it was it was very black swando was a
very tough season where you know even
Obama Biden none of these guys had
prepared for a pandemic the only one
that knew a pandemic was coming was a
guy named Bill Gates everybody else is
like well yeah but here's the thing you
you you don't know that's true and I
think there was a lot of uncertainty in
March of 2020 the question is what about
November of 2020 December January of
2020 what should he have done what
should have he should have fired fouchy
he should have held these people
accountable for being wrong for lying to
the public on all these different issues
the corrupt medical swamp in DC was a
total disaster I'll tell you what they
also shouldn't have done January of 2021
last few weeks in office they're sending
me missives uh from the White House t
Force saying impose a mask mandate close
restaurants do and I'm just thinking to
myself and the media here would use it
as fodder they would say dtis is not
following the Trump White House task
force and I wasn't that's a true but
they you the media used that as a wedge
so I I think that the whole fouchy and
here's the I think the issue for for the
election going forward is I'm the only
one running that is talking about
bringing accountability for what
happened to this country during coid uh
it's one thing to make a judgment call
that's wrong but it's another thing to
ignore evidence it's another thing to
lie when you tell people like CDC did
that if you take an mnra shot you will
not get coid and you still stand by that
when it's obvious that people are
getting it when you're having the FDA
approve an MRA shot for six-month-old
babies where there's no evidence that
that's benefiting them this is a swamp
this needs to be cleared out I will do
that here's the concern I think with
with a trump nomination is RFK Jr
running as as an independent he would be
the vessel for there's a lot of anti-
fouchy anti-lockdown Voters who are
upset about it sure RFK would be the
vessel in that scenario whereas me as
the candidate I'm the vessel for that
everyone knows I'm going to I'm going to
do a I'm going to hold people
accountable fact I'm going to be in New
Hampshire this week with Florida Surgeon
General Joseph lpo Dr lpo he's been he's
one of the few and he's really the only
person in a position of power that's
actually and he got criticized a lot as
well well that's what I told him I hired
him I said listen what you're doing
you're going to be the only one in
position of power to actually take these
because that was one of the things early
on with me when I was making these
decisions it wasn't just that it was
unpopular I could not get a doctor to
stand with me and say I was right A lot
of them would say it privately but they
were they were scared all their
interviews would get taken down on
YouTube all the do so but Joe I think is
is an example of what you need to be
able to deal with this medical so okay
so let's go okay fair enough because you
know even Republicans will say why is
why is the president keep bragging about
the fact that you know the warp speed
you know the vaccine saved 100 million
people's lives I don't even want it to
like some false that's totally false but
the point when he's saying that right
but let's set that part aside when I
showed the clip of that
video and the left sits there and says
look at these guys they can't even
figure out who they want to be the
speaker of the house they can't even
figure out how to do this look at this
MC McCarthy and look at this Mike
Johnson look what they're going to kick
him out as well and if okay it's it
shows a a a not a unified party but I
want to go back with Trump would you
have won your first ter when he won by
34,000 would I read your book The Moment
he came the day your book came out I
read I'm probably one of the first
people that read your read your book
would you have one Governor ship first
time if he doesn't endorse you and put
those tweets about you would you have
one by 34,000 well here's what I mean
the the the test of that is I won by
34,000 with his endorsement okay four
years later he attacked me 3 days before
the election and I won by 1.5 million
votes so he was at a rally in
Pennsylvania he started launching
attacks against me so not only did he
not support me in my
reelection would you have won the first
time look he yes I would have because W
I would have won because here's the
thing if you look at the voters who
opposed me the first time versus the
voters who then supported me the next
time the number one reason they flipped
from against to four in four years was
Trump trump was a factor in
2018 it didn't matter what I did they
were going to vote against me that was
that was the reason they viewed me as
that and so and it was a Blue Wave
across the country I mean remember
Republicans got wiped out across the
country I mean we got wiped out in the
house we lost a bunch of was no Red Wave
is what you're talking about there was a
Blue Wave in it was a snapback against
against uh against Trump and that's
natural for for a first year in the
midterm um but here's the thing you get
in the office and the question is is you
know what do you do with it and I've
done more with it than anybody who's
who's been in a similar situation the
Poli polic success we've had the
leadership in crisis and then moving the
political pendulum in a direction that
we've done is just uh you you cannot
argue I don't know if I disagree with I
don't know if I disagree with that the
only thing I think about is a a guy
helped you there's different there's a
difference between being a mayor like
I'm sure when you see a mayor like dude
you're mayor right there's a difference
between being a mayor or Congress or
senate or Governor or governor of
Florida California New York Texas these
are Big States you're running a country
you're not running a state if you look
at 13th largest economy in the world
yeah so but the point is that part what
do you say to the audience when they
look at you and okay Governor I love
your policies I'm very happy I'd love
you know for you to be a president I
think you have a lot of great qualities
of being a pray you're family guy you're
this you're that but uh what do you say
to the faction that says you know but
the guy gave you an opportunity to be a
governor how about show loyalty to that
guy what do you say to those people
how's it showing loyalty when he attacks
Me 3 days before before my re-election I
had never done anything to him um even
all the fouchy stuff I I always kept
that private that three days before how
much prior to that did youm communicate
were you guys regularly communicating or
not really I I don't really remember but
I mean at that point that was kind of a
line in the sand like okay all right
that that's what you I mean like and I
have no problem like politics it is what
it is but like we were trying to
engineer a red wave around this country
and to not saddle up and be a team
player in that situation to do it that
was wrong honestly I mean
we we we set a record here for what we
did so so it either didn't affect or was
even helpful in hindsight but but that's
just the reality so you can go and and
and do that to to other candidates and
somehow that's not supposed to change
anything the reality is he did that
because he cared more about himself than
he did about the greater good the
greater good was clearly I win
re-election in Florida we win Super
majorities and we continue to implement
the agenda that's the greater good from
a conservative perspective there no
reason you should have been out there
taking pot shots at me or anybody in
Florida and of he's trash Florida
repeatedly over the last year he gets on
social media he said Cuomo did better in
New
York but that it doesn't make any but I
wasn't a candidate when he was doing
that he was doing that on his own cuz he
was upset that did well so it's all
about him so let me he says Nome did
better he said Cuomo did better now his
whole family moved to Florida under my
governorship but put that aside he has
he has use very left-wing media sources
to say crazy things about Florida so
that's what he's done so what is that
he's not held accountable for anything I
mean there's a strain of people that he
can go out and say whatever he wants and
somehow that's fine and then you say
anything then all of a sudden no that's
not the way it works you put your big
boy pants on you're held accountable for
your conduct he chose to make those
statements and that's fine but those are
false statements if you if you believe
that you would have won 34,000 without
those three uh tweets or without him
endorsing you and him bringing you up
and he's like look at him he's feeling
your shoulders I remember that scene
where he's like look at this guy he's
like a strong guy if you believe you
would have won without him fair but to
the voter that thinks that gave you the
Tipping Point to win different story
they're like listen you got to give this
guy a little bit he he's the reason why
you won the first sem as Governor so but
but here's the thing okay so so
therefore then what if you believe that
therefore uh if I don't think he would
uh he's able to win the 2024 election
I'm supposed to to to to not do what I
think right no you should R if I don't
think he can drain the swamp if I don't
think he's going to be able to be a
position to do it the country is more
important endorsements here there have a
conversation before you ran did you have
a conversation with him saying hey
president I'm thinking about running did
you have any conversation with him I I
have not talked to him since he started
attacking me no no no but pre like let's
just say you're having a thought okay so
for example I'm like okay I'm thinking
about starting my own business before I
started my own insurance company and I
made a run to start my own insurance
company I just got married I had a
meeting with the people I respect not
I wasn't thinking about no because the
reason why is I had a lot of people
really from the end of the 2020 election
I've had people telling me you should
run or not but my view was look I got
more to do here uh I had reelection and
then even after the reelection that was
kind of the the the thing where all
these other candidates did poorly yeah I
showed the Republicans the way to win
nationally and people said if we can do
that we're going to do very well in 24
however even with that I I had my head
down I I got all the stuff I promised in
the campaign I got done all of that in
the legislative session uh we were
knocking out all kinds of issues that
conservatives have been dreaming about
for years so we got that done so that's
just how I think that was my frame of
mind you know I said if there's a things
happen for reason and either they'll
happen or they're not but I wasn't two
years ago saying I'm going to do because
I had so much in in front of me on my
plate I had to show political success
because it's one thing to take these
positions it's one thing to to take
leadership stands and you don't do it
for politics and I'm sure it was stupid
politically in the short term for me to
do some of the stuff I've done but you
do need validation at some point to show
that that this is a sustainable model uh
Florida's model and we showed that and
we were able to do it you 100% so you
know back then there was always the talk
should he run should he not run it's
like no listen you when's the next time
you're going to have a chance for we to
have this great of a resume during the
most unpredictable season we've had in
the last 40 years 50 years and you
proved yourself and you ran you should
have ran that's not what I'm saying my
only thing is what is there that
conversation to say you were before me
you helped me with my first governorship
can I have a conversation this is what
I'm thinking I'd like us to be unified
when we go out to the public that is the
only conversation I'm having let me go
to the next conversation next topic here
okay so uh uh when I think about uh
presidents I think about two different
types of presidents I think about a
president that's an alpha and then I
think about presidents that are flag
carriers let me explain to both Alpha to
me is Lincoln was an alpha uh ulysis S
Grant is a flag carrier he became a term
after him uh Reagan Alpha senior flag
carrier uh Kennedy Alpha uh if you go to
uh we got a list of them we can go to uh
Ike Alpha Nixon flag carrier great
president you take Watergate out Nixon
was one of the better presidents be had
the last 50 years you go to Obama Alpha
Clinton Alpha Bush flag carry to his
father Trump Alpha do you view yourself
as an alpha candidate or a flag carrier
candidate no you're a leader of course I
mean you look what we've done in Florida
we blazed the trail I wasn't carrying
anyone's flag I was the one leading I
was calling the shots I was getting out
you think there's anything wrong with
carrying a flag what's that you think
there's anything wrong with carrying a
flag someone's going to carry your flag
and be your VP there's nothing wrong
with it but the question is is you know
if you look at Reagan he set kind of the
standard so 41 was was operating in his
shadow to kind of carry on the Legacy
but Reagan represented the break from
the failure of the Carter to the present
just like I represented kind of Florida
going we're going against the
establishment we're going against the
coid insanity we're going against the
gender Insanity that we're planning a
flag we're not no we're taking a stand
uh and then we're going to push forward
and so that's what we've done and I
think that's what we need in Washington
that everything's going in the wrong
direction so you need an Abrupt shift
where this bureaucracy is reconstitution
lied where you're able to open up all
the energy production reverse biomics
have good people that'll work for you
because you can make the best decisions
in the world you've got to have people
that are going to implement that policy
in a very hostile bureaucracy and if you
don't have that then you're going to end
up getting kneecapped but that's going
to represent a significant break from
how this country has been governed for
the last uh two or three decades but we
need it because I think the direction
that we're going is not sustainable and
this country will fail unless we get uh
an American Revival let's talk about
Nome against you the debate I understand
a year ago for you guys to debate that
made sense I understand even seven
months ago uh to to choose to debate
with him now is a little weird to me
because you're in the playoffs he's not
he didn't make the playoffs he's not
even in the playoffs right the the only
thing I get when I see something like
this is uh uh where you two May a year
ago have thought neither Trump nor
Biden's going to be there at the end
it's going to be the two of you America
wants a younger face America wants a
younger president that's who we want as
a candidate so let's go ahead and do
that there is no winning for you
debating Nome
look yeah yes here's the reason reason
why because this this whole business is
you got to get attention you got to get
on voters minds and for most of the past
six months it's been mostly focusing on
uh everything that's happening legally
with with with the former president uh
that has drowned out a lot of stuff this
is going to be something that's going to
cut through it's going to get a lot of
attention it's a good debate for the
country so that's one reason because I
want a forum to be able to articulate my
message it is not though a debate about
California versus Florida because that
debate is over people have voted with
their feet they've left California and
record numbers they've moved to Florida
on record numbers what it is a debate on
is about the future of the country so
California represents the petri dish of
American leftism they're five years
ahead of whatever Biden's people are
cooking up in DC so if you want to know
what America would look like 2024 Biden
or maybe a new summer Harris yeah just
look to California California is a
recipe to accelerate the decline of this
country Florida is a model to reverse
the decline of the country and engineer
Revival of the American Spirit and a new
birth of Freedom how and finally the
reason to debate he might be the
candidate I mean I think that the
Republican voters we want we need a
candidate that's going to be able to
take on all comers I mean we look at
Biden we say yeah he's over the hill
he's weak and I think that's true but
they may go with with Newsome they may
go with Harris they may go with somebody
else that could happen and we just have
to be prepared for that but it isn't
because I think that necessarily he's
going to be the candidate I think it's
an important debate I think it's an
important opportunity for me to be able
to express my my record and my views in
a way that's going to be largely
unfiltered because I think we're going
to have a 90 minutes to two hours uh
that we're going to do and I'll bet you
that may get more viewers than the last
Fox debate did that we did at the Reagan
Library I think this may get more
viewers than the last debate with with
Fox L I hate to say that I was there
myself and people were walking out of
that debate it wasn't the craziest
debate to be at okay you talk about
attention are you the type of person
like I have people around me that love
to say Hey fat you got something between
your teeth these are the annoying people
in your life right hey Pat pull your
zipper up you know hey Pat do this the
hey pull one of your socks is lower than
the other one I'm sure your marketing
team points out how they're trying to
troll you in the marketplace okay I'm
sure they're doing that can you bring
this one clip I know you were on uh uh
uh what do you call it on uh uh what was
it Bill Maher and Bill Mah talked about
the boots I've seen you walk with these
boots go and play this clip this on Tik
Tok went viral it doesn't have a million
views it doesn't have you know 10
million views this thing's got 1.2
million likes and and some people are
wondering H what are they I don't even I
haven't seen that what they're they've
not shown this to you okay what they're
trying to say with this is that in your
boots you have
heels no no no those are just standard
off the rack um liuy um how tall are you
how tall are you Governor how tall 5'11
okay
why don't you wear tennis shoes and
dress shoes uh I do wear tennis shoes
when I work out yeah okay I got a gift
for you I'd love for you to wear okay I
shop at FGL okay
and I I don't accept gifts I can't
accept it I totally getor I'm going to
put it here and farag can get a nice
sponsorship and then okay if you weared
you faired I know no but here's the
thing I mean I think with just how
politics works is um you know Yogi Bear
when he was um in the Yankees they said
you know Yogi he doesn't look like a
Yankee you know he doesn't do this and
Yogi's basically like okay you know if
you if you say I'm ugly that's fine but
you know you don't hit a baseball with
your face and so what we're doing is you
know really I think doing the the issues
the leadership people that are poking at
you for different things that's fine but
ultimately that is not I think it's a
sign of strength I think if people had
if they could say he was a horrible
Governor he was this he was that then
they would definitely do it um but uh
they don't do that because I don't think
that they have much there we've been an
exemplary leader we've we've gotten
things done uh we would be somebody that
would be obviously a really strong
candidate that's part of the reason the
media attacks me and everything like
that so I would say this to you I think
if your marketing team talks to you
regularly uh they either share with you
but you you you got such a busy schedule
I'm running night companies half the
time I don't even know what's going on
people tell me did you see this I'm like
I can't see everything so I'm sure
you're not seeing everything but I'm a
big fan of yours okay I am not a fan of
your marketing team I'm just not and I'm
I can say that comfortably you can say I
have one of the best marketing teams no
problem because I think your book was a
Miss I think there's a lot of
opportunities that's been out there that
was a Miss I was on a flight One Time
with Bill O'Reilly why was it a Miss uh
I think your book could have done very
well and I was the number one book in
the country for two weeks yeah it's not
a long time though you you're you're a
guy that should be the leading candidate
for president you were the you were the
best Governor during Co hands down
nobody did it better than you no one you
had a fight you stood up to these
bullies to all these a-holes that were
trying to manipulate the voters like me
and we were walking around as if we're
weird and you stood up for those people
and I loved it I respected it I went
around defending you constantly and I'm
sitting there saying why are we not
telling this story why are we not going
out there selling millions of copies of
this book on what you did during Co so
that to me was a was a missed
Opportunity by the way your marketing
team can hate me I've talk to
opin with the book I don't I didn't
really have a marketing team I mean you
know you're doing it and people sell it
or they don't sell it I go on I go on
media and what you didn't go around
talking to a lot of people about your
book though that was a great book we
tried I mean yeah but you know don't
forget I was also in the midst of the
legislative session I had a lot on my
plate and we were doing a lot of stuff I
get that I I just think that was a
missed uh Opportunity by the way if you
haven't read the book I highly recommend
you go order the book there's the book
Rob put the link below to the book
everybody it ended up becoming a New
York time bestseller but it wasn't
really talked about enough I highly
recommend everybody to read this book
okay couple other questions here before
we wrap up with the last 16 minutes by
the way the whole purpose of me showing
you this is you ever seen the movie 8
Mile you ever seen M&M's 8 Mile time ago
you ever seen the last part of8 mile
when he's de when he's uh uh you know
going Eminem's going Eminem was just at
the fight with in ganu and fury and and
it was a great fight I actually didn't
think inano was going to do that good he
C he was on the podcast a couple months
ago I'm like this this guy crushed it so
impressive but the way the movie ends
Eminem is on the stage and this other
guy who's punking him who said stuff
about his girl who said stuff about
trailer who set this all this stuff he
make fun of him he's taller than him
he's got all this stuff that's going on
and he just got up and he says look man
here's what you're going to say about me
you're gonna say this about me you're
gonna say that about me you're gonna say
this about me you're gonna say that
about me even with that this is who I am
if you like it great if you don't that's
not my problem that's your problem
I feel like you know when I look at you
you remember the uh uh the commercial in
the '90s with you know Gatorade
commercial sometimes I dream that he is
Me Like Mike I want to be remember that
whole commercial right okay iconic
commercial yeah so we all wanted to be
like Mike except it's tough to do when
you're from Iran and your vertical leap
is 15 inches I I was not like Mike I was
barely like Muhammad I couldn't jump if
I tried jumping wasn't my thing I was
just a fast
guy so for me when I when I watch
branding wise I'll say who who does your
marketing team try to you know position
you as is it hey let's look at the case
study of jnf Kennedy and Jackie Kennedy
because Casey obviously Casey first of
all when we came that day to the to the
mansion holy moly she's a rock star I
mean I mean you know this I don't need
to tell you this she's your wife but
she's a rock star the way she spoke the
way she won us over the way she would
just you know very gentle kind loved her
husband protective Prime Prime for first
lady she's got all of that right and
it's like well you know is that the case
and do we position John you know you
know uh the governor as John F Kennedy
you're not a playboy you're not a guy
that has that resume that's not you're a
good guy when I look at you you come
across as a great father you're a great
husband that's your brand right so when
you look at yourself and you're being
aspirational do you see yourself and say
you know if I see myself as anybody I
see myself as this President I see
myself as that President and if yes who
would that that be well I don't think
that you I don't think you point to just
one because I think that there's there
unique moments in time and different
people have different things I mean I
think if you look a number of presidents
I mean most recently of course Ronald
Reagan I think the aspirational about
what it means to be an American he was
able to articulate that way in something
that was very very powerful um I think
if you look at some of our Founders
including Washington and some of the
others you know they really had the the
character the idea of of country above
self Washington could have been the king
he could have when we won the revolution
he could have installed himself as a
monarch and he chose not to because he
surrendered his sword and then he went
back to live on his farm in Virginia and
he eventually got called back to be the
first president but when he surrendered
his sword George III said got heard that
in England he said well if he did that
he's the greatest man in the world so
just that sense of of service above self
I think if you look at my background you
know I degrees from Harvard or Yale I
volunteered to serve in the military I
served in uh in Iraq and doing do things
that I didn't have to do I made a lot
less money but I believe in this country
and I believe wearing the uniform is is
Honorable so that ethic combined with
kind of how Reagan uh really was
aspirational about because people were
saying the same things about America in
the 70s that we were bad we couldn't do
it uh we were in Decline and Reagan said
no uh and he got us on a great run for a
while and I think we've stubbed our toe
the last couple decades as a country but
we had 20 plus years of uh of being a
really strong country thanks to his
leadership yeah he was uh he was um he
was a different animal the way he did
things personality was you ever seen
Nixon's movie with Anthony Hopkins no
you've never seen it no highly recommend
you watching it's three and a half first
of all Anthony Hopkins one of the best
it's a 1995 movie and Kissinger in there
if I was ever running I would love to
have that movie to watch that movie of
course I'm sure you've read plenty of
the books that but that movie's got so
many different things to say that guy
reminds me of this guy from this season
that and I just watched it a few weeks
ago highly recommend watching this movie
Nick from 95 it's by Oliver Stone a must
watch uh it'll reveal a lot about a lot
of different people next topic here is
roie Wade
okay so Supreme Court three Trump flips
right for you in Florida this goes from
being a purple State it's about to be a
blue State you come in you flip you pick
up two or I don't know how many you
picked up I think you picked up one or
two right Republican uh where uh uh it
went from being a purple state to a red
state which you were kind of talking
about earlier right in this yeah well
just because of the of the movement of
the electorate in Statewide races now in
22 we we netted an extra four members of
Congress that were Republican to send to
Washington right so in regards to roie
Wade you're watching this Red Wave
doesn't come 2022 okay it's going to
come they're going to crush it it's
going to be McCarthy's not going to need
Gates he's not going to need mag he's
not going to need any of that stuff and
then numbers come out from Pew research
you know 61% of Americans abortion all
this stuff and I think in April of a
year ago or two years ago was 15 weeks
and then you come out April of this year
I want to say it's six weeks what was
your reasoning for wanting to go further
right than Trump on that policy well had
nothing to do with Donald Trump I mean
it was a question of uh when is when
when are you going to protect life and
and the six weeks is to M uh to Mark
when there is a detectable heartbeat for
The Unborn Child So separate heartbeat
separate DNA you know that's a life that
deserves to be protected and so the
legislature was able to enact
protections now they did have exceptions
for all the things that people have
asked for uh and that the Democrats have
attacked on but um at the end of the day
it's a it's a strong protections for
life and it's something that I've always
believed in you know uh you can sit
there and talk about the midterms they
they ran $30 million in ads against me
on this issue they ran against the Iowa
governor Georgia Governor Ohio governor
we all won overwhelmingly uh in that
Texas governor won overwhelmingly so you
know I don't think that was the reason
uh necessarily that that we didn't do as
well it may have been part of it in some
of those races but I think there were
other factors and um I think Florida
clearly showed that uh that you could
get the job done even in the face of
those attacks yeah I I I wonder because
it is a look if you're you're either
pro-life or you're pro-choice right I'm
a Christian so you know where I stand
you know when it comes on to our family
if I had I have 20 kids my wife would be
pregnant every year for the next 20
years but I'm not the one having the
kids I just wonder strategically like
when you're making moves like that
there's certain timing to making moves
like that does that help does that hurt
or that's the right thing to do you do
you do what's right and you let the
chips fall where they may yeah I mean
that's great and I'm I'm curious to know
what that's going to happen with you do
you mind if I ask you a little bit about
people getting to know you a little bit
meaning so are you were you a uh when
you work out what kind of music you
listen to like who who is governor Ronda
sentus working out to are you a Taylor
Swift bigie no Tupac Are You Like Creeds
what do you listen to mostly classic
rock and then sometimes I'll listen to
to uh to to different country country
Rifts and Country tracks so usually one
of those two favorite decade for music
probably the80s yeah me to favorite 80s
song oh my gosh I mean there's too many
to list it's funny I was at an event the
other day and someone's like hey since
you're Gen X you know what's Jenny's
phone number you know 857
875309 so I was able to do that and he's
like I know you I knew you grew up in
the 80s as a result of that so yeah
there was a lot of good stuff back then
you know you and I were four weeks apart
by the way you're you're a Virgo I'm a
Libra I was born four weeks after you uh
favorite documentary of all time okay
let's do it is it Wedding Crashers
hangover Step Brothers or Forgetting
Sarah Marshall what's your favorite I
mean of those doent I'd probably say um
Wedding Crasher weding Crasher I how
many times have you watched Wedding
Crasher you know probably once or twice
but I mean it was good back in the day
that's got to be 20 years old oh my gosh
Vince vaugh one of a kind you know Vince
vaugh was at um so I when I was a US
congressman had Daytona Speedway so I
would do the Daytona 500 every year so
Vince vaugh was one of the celebrity
guests one year and they they put
everyone who was a marshall in a pace
car so it was me and my wife in one
Vince vongh was in another I think they
had a couple musicians and I I kind of
forget who they were they're they're
notable um and so we're all going around
you do the first two laps to start the
race for whatever reason our car zoomed
ahead of the other pace cars so we're
going around the track once around the
track twice then you pull in you go into
the infield
and you pull into this parking lot and
there's like a fence and there's all
these fans there that are waiting for
the celebrities to come so they all have
their phones out my wife and I get out
they see our faces and immediately all
their phones go right back into their
pocket because no one knew who the heck
we were then Vince came and everyone's
going crazy doing all this other stuff
so that was kind of the one time you
know I was ever with him but um you know
he's um I think politically is is not a
lefty like a lot of the Hollywood people
are no he's not he's like one night I'm
uh this is 20 years ago I used to play
at Hollywood Park Casino I would play uh
what do you call it poker and one night
I go there my friend Fernando who ended
up being one of my Grooms when heor we
go there and they say there's a main
table look who's playing there who John
favro and Vince vaugh and this other guy
from Christmas Story whoever the I don't
know what the guy's name was I went and
played with these guys by the way Vince
looked like he had just waken up he got
out out of bed and he he was doing that
movie with Jennifer Anderson at at the
time I don't know what the movie was
called we played poker till 5:00 he's
exactly the way he's one of the funniest
guys out there sports team who's your
favorite sports team uh bucks Tampa Bay
Bucks Tampa Bay Bucks that's right I
grew up in the Tampa Bay Area when they
had the orange creamsicle uniforms Tampa
Bay I was there when the old the old
sombrero and uh how bad those teams were
and uh won a won a title 20 years ago
and then with Tom Brady a few years ago
so yeah favorite movie of all time
probably Rocky which one Rocky one first
one I think so Underdog yeah you relate
to that a little bit is that a little
bit of your personality I think so I
mean look I think if you look at at
where I am now in life where I started
no very few people they would have taken
the under on any of the stuff I've done
um up to this point but I do think that
hard work and just you know tension and
and and getting the most out of your
god-given ability I still think in
America that matters may not matter as
much as it should and we need to make it
matter more again yeah but I do think
that that's what makes this country
great why do you enjoy
politics oh man why do you enjoy this
game this is a weird game to like people
sometimes ask me like why did you first
run for office and I usually like why
did you run for Congress and I'm like
momentary laps in judgment um you know
there's a lot of negative about it I me
look I think in this this business
you're able to to do things to to really
have an impact on people's lives I mean
I will still to this day have people
come up to me who I do not know give me
a hug start crying and saying saying you
saved my business or you saved my job or
you saved my kids' education we brought
people back from Israel my wife and I
were waiting at the tarmac 271 people uh
91 children on that flight you know
giving us big hugs thank you so much all
this stuff so all the day-to-day stuff
the nonsense you deal with ultimately it
doesn't matter and what matters is you
know what are you doing to to uh help
people and make life better we've been
able to probably have more of an impact
on a greater number of people uh
Governor than any Governor has been able
to in a long time and and that's making
the most of it Governor Dan Sanz how do
you sell America if you were to sell
America to me like when I was at the
first debate and the second debate and I
I I keep listening to so many about
policies policies policies policies
everybody's policies policies okay
there's a percentage of America probably
relates to the policies right but if if
one asked you sell me and sell the
American people why you think America is
the greatest country in the world what
would you say
well at at our best uh our country is
one where it doesn't matter where you
start it doesn't matter your family
lineage uh that if you work hard get the
most of your god-given ability if you
believe in what this country's
principles are uh that you can do well
and that has not been true in other
countries throughout human history
wherever you're born that pretty much
limited or not your your lot in life if
you had privileged birth you had higher
aspirations if you didn't you had lower
uh here uh you have an field and a fair
chance uh for your industry and
Enterprise to ultimately flourish uh
we're losing that that's one of the
reasons why I'm W for president uh but
at our best that's that's what we are I
love it uh Rob can we put the link to
the governor's website for anybody who
can donate uh and to his campaign to do
so I've done that my wife's done that
our family's done that and uh we we've
supported multiple people in this run I
think it's a very uh important run that
we're having you're very formidable
opponent that's going on here the
climate is strange I I would have loved
to have seen you and Trump run in a
different way where it was more unified
but every you know game changes seasons
change we'll see what happen about that
I mean that that was kind of his so so
by the way if he called for meeting
would you go visit with him if he called
you and said hey let's you and I have a
meeting and figure out a way to unify
the Republican Party would you go to Mar
Lago I mean I'd take a phone call I
don't think I'd make a pilgrimmage down
there um but the reality is is that
that's obviously not the not the course
he's choosing and and the question is is
uh what's the best foot forward for the
country it's ultimately not about him
it's ultimately not about me it's about
how do you get this country moving again
who's the best vehicle for the
Republican party to put up to win and to
deliver on all this stuff and I'm
running because I think I am I think I'm
the only guy running who can win the
primary the general and actually deliver
all these things over an eight-year
period to where the country in January
of 2033 after serving two terms pass the
Baton off hopefully to a worthy
successor I'll be able to tell the
country we restored the American dream
we got the we secured the Border uh we
we strengthened our military fended off
the threat from China education not
indoctrination parents rights no crime
in the the criminals aren't ruled in the
streets and the cities anymore rain in
the Deep state in the bureaucracy all
those things we've got to get them done
and I will do that I love it once again
respect you for coming out you said you
were going to come out you did I
appreciate you so much means a lot to us
thank you for your time thank you again
appreciate you for coming out appreciate
you thank you thank you everybody y
bye-bye